Russia's defense ministers accuse
Ukraine of planning to use what's called
a dirty bomb Sergey shoigum is reported
of voiced his concerns during three
phone calls with his counterparts in the
UK France and Tokyo a dirty bomb is an
explosive laced with radioactive
material Moscow has provided no evidence
to back up the claims the Russian
defense Ministry says the war in Ukraine
has a steady tendency towards further
uncontrolled escalation well Ukraine's
denied the allegations with foreign
minister dimitro Kaleb are calling the
claims absurd and saying Russia often
accuses others of what they're planning
to do while Harry fawcetts is joining us
live now from Keith Harry another twist
in the war in Ukraine
yes and another potential escalation
even if it doesn't turn out to be an
escalation on the battlefield I think we
can safely call this an escalation in
terms of the Diplomatic rhetoric being
used and the sheer number of calls four
of them on the same day to the French
the Turkish the British and the
Americans all making this same claim
that Russia has it says intelligence of
the formation of some kind of dirty bomb
for use by Ukraine to blame Russia for
carrying out some kind of nuclear
explosion inside Ukraine now this is
something that has been as you say
utterly refuted by the Ukrainian
government the foreign minister Dimitri
culeba as well as the the comments that
you noted there he also said that uh
Ukraine is a member of the
non-proliferation treaty and that it
neither has the um the the material nor
the ambition to acquire such material to
carry out such an attack we've also
heard from the UK defense Ministry uh
the defense minister Ben Wallace having
this conversation with defense minister
to shoigu and the UK is saying that it
refuted these claims and cautioned that
such allegations should not be used as a
pretext for greater escalation now
something else that kaleba the foreign
minister here said was uh that Russia
often does this ahead of something that
it plans to do itself there are analysts
looking back at the course of the war in
Syria the uses of chemical weapons
during that conflict and the either
retroactive or sometimes preemptive
blaming of such attacks by Russia on
Rebels helped by Western countries they
named Britain in at least one of those
instances as well so this is extremely
concerning especially given the fact
that Russia does seem to be withdrawing
both civilians and potentially military
personnel and equipment from the area
around her son this very hotly contested
Ukrainian city which Russia occupied
back in March and they accuse Ukraine of
manufacturing this supposed
dirty bomb device not too far away from
there as well so these are certainly
worrying signals whether it is Bluster
whether it is something more we have to
wait and see
Harry thank you very much I did Harry
fossa talking to us from Keith